mec, je vous ai tous vu en retard pour continuer à
faire votre truc pour dire bonjour je vous ai vu pour
ma suite où le grand état du
Michigan je suis un nouvel endroit ici je n'ai jamais
été à cet endroit avant nous un
petit rebord ici
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Damien Cena et je suis un
skateur qui se trouve être aveugle, la
plupart des gens ont une idée de la vinosité
qui est faussée et c'est juste parce qu'on ne le
sait pas ou qu'on ne l'expérimente pas, vous
ne sauriez pas vraiment à quoi ça ressemble, alors
vous savez qu'essayer de  faire ma part pour changer
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu ne remarques pas vraiment que tu perds
la vue ce n'est pas comme si tu voyais des angles
morts tu vois toujours n'importe
quelle vision ou champ de vision  la vue que
vous avez c'est tout ce que vous voyez donc vous
ne remarquez pas vraiment ce que vous ne voyez pas au
milieu des années 20, c'est quand cela a commencé à
m'affecter réellement et les choses que j'ai faites et
c'est en quelque sorte à ce moment-là que j'ai arrêté de conduire
et perdu beaucoup de  mon indépendance qui est une
chose énorme à perdre et à gérer
tout a été affectée mon  la vie, donc j'en suis
finalement arrivé au point où je
ne voudrais pas quitter ma maison Je
ne pouvais même pas aimer me promener dans mon quartier
sans être avec quelqu'un
qu'une partie entière de ma vie était
terminée, il y a beaucoup de stigmatisation et ces
perceptions et idées que les gens ont
sur les aveugles et que je supposais
être vraies sur les aveugles m'ont pris
quelques années pour réaliser qu'ils devaient
arrêter de chercher quoi  une personne aveugle
est et me concentre juste sur ce que j'étais
et ce que je voulais faire et
c'était du skate pour moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
J'ai commencé à réaliser que les gens
me traitaient différemment en tant
qu'aveugle et je voulais en quelque sorte
repousser cela alors j'ai commencé à faire ces
vidéos Instagram de moi faisant des choses pour lesquelles
on ne s'attendrait pas nécessairement à ce qu'une
personne fasse
[Musique]
et puis j'ai eu l'idée d'en faire une de
skate alors j'ai construit un peu
banc et j'ai patiné c'est k
un peu comme un lent ravivage progressif de cette
passion ou de ce feu, vous savez, les gens
étaient comme ravis de ces vidéos afin qu'ils
puissent je suppose que je patinerai un peu
plus et puis j'ai réalisé comme oh je peux
aimer en fait encore faire ça et encore
amusez-vous et progressez toujours et
obtenez juste cet épanouissement un peu
comme j'aime l'avoir fait une fois que je ne
pensais pas pouvoir faire
[Musique]
J'ai l'habitude de compter sur les ombres  avait un
peu plus de vision maintenant tout est éteint
sentir que tout est éteint utiliser ma canne et mes
mains pour sentir les objets il s'agit d'utiliser le
chronométrage en commençant à une certaine distance d'
un obstacle puis en commençant au
même endroit de sorte que lorsque je roule
suffisamment  fois finalement j'ai une
idée du moment où je vais, vous
savez, approchez-vous de l'objet ou approchez-vous de
lui, puis utilisez ma canne pour taper dessus
[Applaudissements]
nous avons la perruque à Detroit sur le point de donner
sa planche à Dan, je ne  Je ne pense pas qu'il le sache
, donc c'est sur le point d'être un
moment assez surréaliste, je veux dire, je ne sais pas  connais beaucoup de
patineurs aveugles que
tu aimeras dans ou en général
très bien merci d'être venu
c'est l'anniversaire de van cheetahs aujourd'hui nous
aimons que tout le monde nous aide à lui souhaiter un
joyeux anniversaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique
]  dans une courbe aveugle
et tenter de défier les yeux bandés,
je vais construire un skatepark
conçu pour les skateurs
malvoyants qui utilisera
Universal Design afin qu'il soit accessible
à tout type de handicap et à tout
ce que vous diriez entre guillemets
vous connaissez une personne normale ou une
personne qui fonctionne normalement, vous savez si c'est
comme des adaptations ou des sons ou tout autre
indice qui vous aide à savoir que vous utilisez tous les
sens du corps pour vous aider à naviguer et à patiner les
obstacles, puis, espérons-le, utilisez-le
pour les futurs parcs qui sont
les enfants construits et les personnes qui grandissent et
vivent avec une déficience visuelle et la
cécité n'ont pas toujours les mêmes
opportunités que le monde voyant et
j'essaie de faire ma part pour introduire le
skateboard dans  ces personnes, en particulier
vous connaissez des enfants aveugles et
malvoyants et leur donnez juste l'
occasion d'expérimenter autant
qu'ils le peuvent, expérimentez quelque chose de
différent,
ne vous laissez pas dicter par ce que les autres
pensent que vous êtes capable de faire parce que si je faisais
ça et que je  aurait certainement
patiné donc il faut
comprendre ce que vous aimez et comment le faire
vous